a lead magnet is not a partial solution
what a lot of people try and do is like
hey I'm going to give you the first six
minutes of this 12 minute video and get
the rest click here right I think that's
not the right way to do it I think you
lose trust and that's literally the
opposite of the objective of lead mic
there's lots of little things that can
happen in a transaction and the bigger
thing is the more steps there are if
you're trying to sell a house you've got
to clean the house you got to put the
sign out you got to figure out how it
could increase the value can I pick one
of these very painful steps for my
Prospect and solve it for them at a
massive discount to attract more people
to want to do it with me and I do such a
good job at this massive discount that I
increase the trust they have with me and
now they have one foot in the door you
handle this so well and so expediently
why would I not want to do more work
with you